it's almost like a big goose flying in
the air with its feet down here and this
is a somewhat of a lenticular cloud out
there it's kind of being buffeted by the
winds upper level wind so it kind of
smooths the clouds out that are in the
sky
we're going to see more of those winds
developing as we get through the day did
you see the full moon that was over the
weekend oh my goodness it was the april
full moon the pink moon and this picture
was sent by sean morris
took the photo from the virgin mountains
just as it was starting to set so
thank you so much sean appreciate that
really really a beautiful shot pix
8newsnow.com that's our email address if
you ever have weather photos or anything
you'd like to share with us lots of 60s
around town some 50s up north and
northwest nellis is down to 52. kyle
canyon's got some breezes up there this
morning so those winds are going to be
increasing for all of us as we get
through the day then downright windy on
tuesday that's going to be the rough
wind day for us this week 38 in
caliani 56 in mesquite 48 in indian
springs and near 60 in boulder city with
mid 60's in laughlin paramp you've got
57. reno will be getting in on a little
rain and snow this week with a series of
systems pushing into the west a lot of
red red flag warnings we'll talk about
those and look at the winter snow that
continues to spin into the great lakes
through the upper midwest lots of rain
and that's turning to snow and freezing
rain as it heads towards the northeast
today into tonight low pressure system
way up north but it's got that trailing
cold front and that cold front is what's
going to pull up those strong southwest
winds for our area tomorrow a few high
clouds coming into the area off and on
today the blue is wind advisories then
on top of that fire weather warnings
those are in red for dry windy
conditions tomorrow
9 a.m to 9 00 p.m so just critical fire
weather for tuesday 91 today will be the
warmest day of the week then
temperatures slide into the 80s but
really windy we're talking 40 45 mile an
hour winds tomorrow
not as windy but still kind of breezy on
wednesday and then we'll get another
system thursday with more wind and that
one's going to be cooler 70s on friday
with a slight chance of showers for now
we hope to increase those chances
between now and then